two of the strangest but most powerful
Concepts in Psychology are called
variously sadism and masochism by sadism
is understood an enjoyment in causing
other people's suffering and by
masochism an enjoyment in receiving ill
treatment from others though commonly
associated with sexual scenarios these
drives operate in all areas of life at
the office or in the schoolyard as much
as in the bedroom or the dungeon so why
do they exist why do we seem to Delight
in inflicting suffering or even more
strangely take satisfaction in enduring
it the best way to understand the
phenomena is to view them as attempts to
deal with an earlier intolerable
experience of fear cruelty or unkindness
before anyone winds up either a sadist
or a masochist they've first been a
victim subsequent behaviors are a
reflection reflection of the mind's
concerted attempts to find a way out of
a naked encounter with pain masochists
and sadists are both trying to ensure
that they will survive what once felt
like it might annihilate them the sadist
hits on the more straightforward move
having received cruelty they conclude
that the best way to escape its shadow
is to be cruel to somebody else the
poison is redirected outwards the former
terrified child becomes a terrifying
adult implicitly the sadist believes
that there are only two roles available
victim or perpetrator and that their
best chances of never again ending up as
the former is to ensure that they will
always be the latter masochists have
like sadists also been the victims of
Cruelty like sadists they are also in
flight from defenselessness but their
method of adaptation is more roundabout
a sense of weakness real or imagined
holds them back from attempts to
persecute other people and yet they
still need some psychological way of
alleviating the memory of suffering and
so they hit upon what could almost be
labeled an ingenious idea they decide
that they will henceforth choose
suffering rather than having it forced
upon them they opt to turn a necessity
into something akin to a choice once
they had no option but to be bullied by
their family of birth now they go out in
active surch of mean-minded Partners
whom they can unconsciously tell will
deny them tenderness and Care once they
were told by others that they were a
failure now they ruin their own chances
before anyone else has the opportunity
to do it for them to liberate ourselves
we need to find our way back to the pain
that lies behind our behaviors and then
we should do something that we have
until now avoided mourn what we have
gone through we should exchange pain for
sorrow we should cry for what we have
had to endure not ask anyone else it
might be a stranger or as regrettably
ourselves to suffer any further